now one group of people likely to be
vulnerable during the coming extreme
temperatures are the homeless the mayor
of london sadiq khan says emergency
measures have now been put in place to
help
this year for the first time we've
issued a severe weather emergency
response in summer normally we do this
in winter when it gets really cold and
it's dangerous for people to be sleeping
out in the cold weathers what we've done
this year working with excellent
councils and charities
is issued a severe weather emergency
response now
skies matthew thompson has been out this
morning with volunteers in london
you join me from victoria station which
is in london's city of westminster which
is the london borough with the highest
number of known rough sleepers and by
extension the highest number in the
country it's three times more rough
sleepers here in westminster than there
are in the next highest london borough
which is camden so it's an acute problem
most of the year particularly so though
when the temperatures are set to rise as
high as they are so we've been out with
workers from the charity mungos who are
doing things like providing water
providing sun cream shelter to
vulnerable people who are out on the
streets i caught up with one of the
workers matthew griffiths a short time
ago to explain why it's so important the
charity does what it does
during the hot weather
our client group tend to be more
vulnerable they have various physical
health conditions that make them more
vulnerable to the heat some of them are
on medications such as antipsychotic
medications and epileptic medications
which
don't react well with the heat
and also some of our clients who have
issues with
substance use issues and mental health
tend not to look after themselves when
it gets really hot so you'll find them
in big groups in the daytime hot spots
um
in the blazing sun maybe drinking and
and
not looking after themselves so we want
to encourage them to take respite and
stay hydrated basically
now of course homelessness is just one
area of concern there are many others
like transport for example railways
likely to be affected tarmac apparently
can melt the temperatures that we might
be expecting on monday and tuesday in
large parts of england also the nhs will
struggle increasing numbers of people
presenting with heat exhaustion heat
stroke and things like that ambulances
overstretched we understand there's
going to be a potential cobra meeting
government cobra meeting later today as
they try and coordinate the crisis so
it's fairly clear that across a host of
issues we're going to expect fairly
widespread disruption to british life
come monday and tuesday next week